[Laughter]
good work
good wow is that is it look good do you
like it you're a natural
are you proud of me dad oh your head
jacob jumped in click on it pull it
oh yeah so yeah
it's the headless twerker so once
everyone's in here okay
who's this man in my face i've got the
camera here
why you got your thumb in the lens fam i
think you right-click to use it so if
y'all look over here
there's uh some optional objectives okay
okay discover what type of ghost we're
dealing with
capture a picture of the ghost capture a
picture of
dirty water in a sink prevent the ghost
from hunting with a crucifix
do we have a crucifix i've done some
more investigating for you nice that was
a good picture now careful you only have
a certain amount of photos there
okay okay this coast also seems to only
respond to people who are alone
you should be able to okay well it's to
be able to use its
name to anger it and get some paranormal
activity
make sure to refer to your journal and
write down any any evidence you find
all right everyone do we want to try to
do a voice why do we need to leave the
lobby at all i don't understand oh my
god
okay all right grabbing a torch i've got
the video camera i think
why did did it just sound to anyone else
like jacob inhaled helium
this is awesome okay i'm scared john you
have the flashlight
i'm the only one with a flashlight so i
have maybe i think i have a uv
light which you think has come all over
this house
oh
what is this the haunting apply mana
i can't see [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] scared
me too
i don't give a [ __ ] thank god
i'm just going to stay with you all
because you said the ghost doesn't like
people unless they're alone and i
don't want to be alone don't leave me
where are you going oh there's something
there there's something there
what what what
where are the light switches the lights
are off again the lights are off again
rahul i just saw you shut that door you
piece of [ __ ]
over what is this is a bone i found a
bone maybe
we've got a case of a narcissist
masturbating in the mirrors
oh my god they are right i know
looking for signals did you [ __ ] do
that rahul oh no the lights
the lights
what were our other objectives well
other than find her what were our other
objectives you guys
whoa did john it was just like john
uh-oh
john
john john john what happened
john i think he's [ __ ] dead
john he went down to the basement
oh no one choice we gotta go without
he's done john i see you
sean i'm getting levels i'm getting
oh oh lights all right
the mirror the mirror look in the mirror
yeah it's just oh
whoa the signal don't think we're
supposed to take a picture of the days
yeah yeah we're going
on i have a camera what do i do what do
i do what do we do
take a picture of the dirty sink i
thought that was for the last one
uh did i do it i'm getting levels over
here okay i took the photo
do i write about this john yeah right
put it up put the book on the ground
whoa what is that
above us
[Laughter]
oh my god okay
walked in here what's happening
what happened to you did he die
i think he's dead jacob
what happened okay
what happened to you said your wife what
happened to john
isn't this wrong or is it john
something wrote do you hear that jacob
do you hear that
yes okay we are not brave we need to do
something
not even a [ __ ] little bit where is
everyone oh my god
have you seen him have you seen what
happened to rahul bro
oh wait
he's standing in the corner no he's dead
on the floor
look somebody wrote some symbols in the
book yeah
he's flipping over [ __ ] god damn it
there we go oh my god
oh flickers flickers over here
okay let me take him off you gotta get
em effing nothing detected nothing
guys i'm gonna go check the camera real
quick nothing
the door don't open no more sandra
but what do we do when she gets out here
oh i heard a creek
there's creeks we take a picture of him
all the lights went out and there are
creeks
son of a [ __ ] this is a terribly
uh
a carp i could see anything is the door
locked is the front door locked
uh what is that is that one of you
no no that's gotta be a ghost you guys
no that's gotta be a ghost that's a
ghost that's gotta be
that's a hundred percent not one of me
okay
okay john we might need camera it hasn't
spiked but
what what's that what what's that what's
happened to what's happened
what's happened to jacob what happened
to jacob
let's let's just let's get out of here
okay
oh my gosh what happened to jacob
oh pizza you're almost completely insane
don't worry about it do you have the
folder do we to go get the notebook
real quick john where are you john
john where where is what what what
what johnny you okay
johnny okay john
john oh everyone's dead
they're all dead
oh [ __ ]
welcome
[Laughter]
everybody died and i didn't know what
happened and i got really nervous
and